u.s secretary of defense lloyd austin
has secured an agreement from philippine
president rodrigo duterte to restore
a key pact allowing military exercises
between the two countries to continue
american naval presence in the
indo-pacific is seen by many southeast
asian states
as a counterbalance to a rising china
beijing has claimed sovereignty over
large parts of the nearby south china
sea even
constructing artificial islands for its
navy and air force
secretary austin said his visit was
meant to underscore the importance of
the relationship with the philippines
which is the us's oldest ally in asia
joining us is journalist j.c gatinga in
manila
j.c this looks like a win for the biden
administration
is this a win for the philippines
you know melissa looking at the broader
picture of where the philippines
finds itself in in terms of its
geopolitics at the moment
it is to be considered largely also a
win for the philippines in terms
of its uh credible defense spot or its
ability to stand up against
any possible aggression from china you
see the united states is the philippines
only uh treaty military ally
and that agreement that was reaffirmed
today it's called the visiting forces
agreement
besides allowing for military exercises
between the philippines and the u.s
it actually basically allows the united
states to maintain
a considerable military presence in the
philippines that would otherwise be
prohibited under the law
now experts here in manila agree that
this visiting forces agreement
is what operationalizes it it gives
these to the alliance between the
philippines
and the us which means without it even
if there is that alliance on paper
should there be any need for the united
states to come to the philippines as aid
in a military sense
it would be very difficult to do so
given that the nearest base of the us
would probably be
japan guam or even hawaii as opposed to
having its troops and some assets
already in place in the philippines
now there's of course been a long
dispute between the philippines
and china in the south china sea and in
fact
nila took a case to the united nations
which ruled in manila's favor where do
things
uh where do things stand with those
contested waters
do we have fishermen out there do we
have military patrols out there
well in recent months the philippines
has stepped up uh
patrols in what what it calls the west
philippine sea
this is the area that the united nations
tribunal affirmed
to be the philippines as a rightful area
within the south china sea including its
200 nautical mile
exclusive economic zone and other other
territories that are disputed
by different countries in the area um
where it stands uh despite this
stepped-up presence it really was a
reaction to this increasing
number of chinese vessels that are
regularly
found present in philippine waters these
are not just
these fishing boats that the philippine
government and even experts around the
world agree to be
manned by chinese militias but also
there have been increasing reports of
chinese warships and a steady presence
of chinese coast guard vessels
in key areas of the south china sea uh
the international community and the
previous government of the philippines
right the filipino public in general
have uh
hope that this arbitral award uh that
the government would capitalize on it to
kind of push back against beijing but
the duterte administration has largely
set that aside
uh in favor of uh warmer ties with
beijing yeah i want to talk a little bit
about that
president rodrigo duterte has in the
past flattered
chinese leader xi jinping and seemed to
want to build friendlier relations with
china
where does things stand has he entirely
pivoted from that position with
the news that we're just hearing from
lloyd austin's visit
not at all melissa in fact just last
monday duterte was still added
criticizing the united states
uh his accusations basically were that
the united states have been an unfair
ally to the philippines that it has not
lived up to expectations
of what each country brings to the table
in terms of military aid of course the
philippines
is um on the weaker side of the military
spectrum
here obviously um but yeah there uh
duterte maintains a very friendly stance
against or
towards china uh he calls xi jinping his
friend in fact he wants it that he
simply loves
xi jinping and it's a consistent theme
throughout his addresses
his rhetoric whenever he's confronted
with anything relating to china he is
always
uh sounding favorable to beijing it
sounds like he's trying to
win both the united states and china and
play both sides
jc gotenga thanks so much for joining us